je pense que j'ai pleuré sur elle et
j'ai pleuré aussi sur sur ce qui m'est
arrivé trois ans auparavant
de son vivant la princesse de Galles
était un phénomène de mode la star de la
presse à scandale sa mort en a fait plus
qu'une légende un mythe moderne presque
une religion pourquoi sommes-nous
devenus les orphelins de Lady Di sa vie
était-elle si exemplaire pour que nous y
projetions nos rêves nos espoirs nos
vies sont-elles si insatisfaisantes pour
que nous ayons besoin de la sanctifier
le culte de Lady Di est-ce le monde à
l'envers ou une autre façon de regarder
notre vie
[Musique]
on a fait plus de 530 km jusqu'ici qu'on
place d'Alma pour voir spécialement
l'hommage à Lady Diana
[Musique]
on serait venu d'Alger spécialement on
voulait que je l'amène là pour l'avoir
c'est très symbolique parce que ils ont
été très touchés là-bas
à Paris ne pas voir Diana quand même
c'est brûler une étape pour moi c'était
le brûler une étape il fallait que je
fasse ah oui j'avais insisté j'avais
assisté
on vient ici moi je dis ça ça dépasse la
Tour Eiffel quoi c'est à dire que
l'hommage quoi c'est c'est plus fort que
de voir la Tour Eiffel
je pense que le la rose blanche
symbolise la princesse c'était elle
était pure elle était gentille elle
était elle représentait la famille des
Halles et
à travers elle
on se reconnaissait un peu avec toutes
les souffrances que toutes les femmes
peuvent souffrir que 100% qu'on en parle
quoi ça peut prouver que même dans ce
monde là les gens sont aussi malheureux
et dans le monde des
des gens simples
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de
dire cette cette dame Diana était
vraiment comme vous oui je pense
vraiment sincèrement elle a un coeur
comme tout le monde et pas parce qu'on
est princesse qu'on ne ressent pas des
émotions aussi forte que les nôtres donc
oui vraiment je pense tout à fait et
alors qu'est-ce que vous retrouvez en
Diana elle a perdu la vie au moment où
moi je donnais la vie donc elle avait
encore beaucoup de choses à faire sur
terre et c'est pour ça que ça a perdu la
vie
mon fils je l'ai eu à 36 ans donc elle
est morte à 36 ans c'est vrai que bon
moi j'ai commencé une vie de maman à ce
moment-là elle elle pouvait également
construire une femme qu'elle n'avait pas
eu auparavant avec d'autres enfants etc
et c'est vrai que c'est c'est très
troublant c'est très émouvant tout ça
vraiment ça m'a vraiment fait de la
peine vraiment de la peine
alors Christine vous vous avez on va
dire 50 ans pratiquement vous êtes
secrétaire comptable vous avez un enfant
un enfant donc sans avoir été marié
alors j'ai posé sur la table plusieurs
photos
pour vous en choisissiez une qui vous a
particulièrement ému je vais regarder
narcissique tout de suite tout de suite
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit
c'est la tendresse la tendresse partagez
la tendresse donnée l'amour de nez
vraiment le trop plein d'amour qu'elle
donne à son fils c'est ce que vous
ressentez vous aussi par rapport à votre
enfant puisque vous êtes seul à l'élever
oui ben on a un trop plein d'amour quand
on ne partage pas on fait pas un genre
de triangle perle la mère l'enfant donc
automatiquement il manque un des
éléments de la figure géométrique si je
peux dire et les deux les deux ans que
ce reportent sur une seule personne dans
ces cas-là mais elle était mariée
justement contrairement à vous oui mais
elle était mariée mais mal mariée
c'est-à-dire malmain elle croyait
certainement épouser le prince qu'elle
croyait charmant et puis qu'il était pas
pas tant que ça vous êtes pas marié
parce par choix parce que vous n'aviez
pas envie
parce qu'à un moment donné vous êtes
retrouvé seul avec cet enfant parce qu'à
un moment donné je ne me suis retrouvée
seule c'est vrai que on fait un enfant
des fois par choix mais on s'imagine
toujours aussi que derrière le choix va
être partagé bon là l'occasion de ce
n'est pas présenté donc j'ai assumé ce
que l'enfant que j'avais que j'avais mis
au monde je l'ai assumé mais elle aussi
correspond à une femme qui assume son
destin pas tout de suite peut-être
puisqu'il y avait une timidité etc mais
au début on a on l'a connu un peu
rougissante et regarde par en dessous la
timidité mais quand elle a relevé petit
à petit la tête elle a elle a vu la vie
en face elle a elle a assumé et c'est ça
qui me plaît en fait en elle quand vous
en parlez on a le sentiment si une
certaine manière qu'elle vous venge de
quelque chose bon j'ai peut-être pas bon
je crois
un petit peu fort
voilà je suis toute la vie d'accord avec
vous à ce niveau là ça serait une
revanche de quoi Christine alors mais en
revanche en montrant qu'on peut très
bien se passer bon ben ma foi si ça si
ça ne marche pas on peut très bien
avancer aussi et bon bah c'est passé pas
utile vaut mieux être seul que mal
accompagné est-ce qu'auparavant vous
aviez déjà éprouvé des choses comme
celle-ci est-ce que à l'occasion d'un
autre événement vous aviez repensé à
votre vie ou c'est la première fois
c'est la première fois donc je pense
c'est vrai sérieusement c'est vrai donc
j'ai je me suis rendu compte que j'avais
fait un cheminement inconscient dans ma
tête bon je sais pas enfin je suis
quelqu'un enfin qui va de l'avant donc
il essaye le moins possible de regarder
ce qui se passe derrière soi mais un
moment donné c'est bien de faire le
point il faut des événements
malheureusement tragiques pour vous
permettre de faire le point sur vos sur
vous-même en général Christine on fait
le point sur soi-même justement à partir
d'un événement
qui est vraiment qui vous appartient
faire quelque chose qui vous touche de
très très près normalement dans sa vie
propre dans sa vie intime pas dans la
vie de quelqu'un d'autre est-ce que vous
comprenez pourquoi ça se passe comme ça
pour vous non vraiment pas mais je pense
ça m'a touché peut-être plus que je ne
veux je ne veux le dire justement pour
que je me pose ces questions je me
rappelle certaines choses
ça a vraiment fait des tenettes voilà
et rien dans votre vie d'avant n'a été
aussi fort comme catalyseur peut-être la
disparition de mon père c'est vrai vous
dites peut-être la disparition peut-être
on en est pas sûr si mais enfin c'est
tout à fait un autre aspect c'est un
autre aspect relation père-fise est un
autre aspect mais
c'est un une tendresse aussi qui part
mais ça m'a moins fait me reporter sur
ma vie de femme ce jour-là vous avez
pleuré quand vous avez appris la
nouvelle j'ai surtout pleuré au moment
de l'enterrement c'est l'enterrement en
fait qui a qui m'a fait revivre
également c'est toujours pareil je
reviens mon problème dentaire mon père
qui m'a fait revivre bon c'est quand on
quand on voit tout ça bon
le cérémonie à entre guillemets je mets
bien les guillemets qui accompagnent
donc le départ de de personnes connues
ou inconnues et quand même similaire
et c'est vrai que je pense que j'ai
pleuré également la voyant partie
par rapport à si c'était passé trois ans
avant des larmes que vous aviez pu avoir
vous avez peut-être pas eu à ce
moment-là parce que des fois on
n'exprime pas tout
on est tellement choqué on est tellement
pris on a tellement l'impression d'avoir
reçu un coup de poignard que les larmes
des fois ne sortent pas tout de suite et
puis on croit qu'elles vont sortir elles
vont jamais sortir et puis il faut un
vecteur pour les voler faire sortir
c'est l'arme là
ça a été le vecteur tout à fait je pense
que j'ai pleuré sur elle et j'ai pleuré
aussi sur sur ce qui m'est arrivé trois
ans auparavant si vous aviez à définir
Lady Di en trois mots qu'est-ce que vous
diriez
bah c'est un justicier en premier maman
femme
qu'est-ce qui manque qu'est-ce qui
manque bah je sais pas amour
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas
[Musique]